before dawn on July 16th 1945 at the
Alamogordo Army Air Base in New Mexico a
small band of military and civilian
technicians waited nervously in the
control Shack was dr. JR Oppenheimer who
assisted by dr. I Ravi and others had
directed the making of the bomb itself
the automatic controls Garrett now
robbed this time stakes are really high
it's going to work all right Robert and
I'm sure we'll never be sorry for it
today the whole world fears the ultimate
devastation which a war of atomic
weapons could bring and the United
States is prepared to cooperate fully in
eliminating by world agreement and for
all time the nightmare of atomic war
this was actually the beginning we've
come down a long road from the Trinity
test and we have a long road ahead since
the dawn of the Atomic Age the world has
experienced a steady buildup of nuclear
arsenal consequently there's a massive
backlog of radioactive waste by the long
ignored stockpiling of nuclear waste has
resulted in a situation where products
designed to protect us are now
threatening our own health and safety
the United States alone is armed with
25,000 nuclear warheads 17 facilities
across the country are involved in the
research design testing and production
of nuclear bombs these facilities have
accumulated approximately 300 million
cubic feet of radioactive waste cleanup
of these sites where possible could cost
100 million at Hanford Rocky Flats
Savannah River and other weapons making
sites citizens are suffering from do-e
negligence in secrecy in recent months
the Department of Energy has at least
been trying to clean house and is now
admitting its own gross mismanagement
states are closing their borders to hot
trash as they come to grips with the
nuclear waste dilemma well it sounds
like you got a bit of a revolt on your
hands out west can you deal with it well
we hope to now we know that the
governor's in the West are very
concerned about our difficulties we
don't want to have permanent storage in
Idaho or Colorado and we're working to
open a facility that's been 10 years in
the making in New Mexico and we have a
few months more months to go on that
well if you only have a few more months
to go then everybody will be happy
because I understand that governor Romer
says the sight in the Colorado will be
full up in four months
are you sure you can open that New
Mexico facility in a few months time
well we were targeted to open up in
October of this year that has been a
better goal for the past five years we
have some additional steps to take some
certifications and some planning that
needs to be completed but principally we
also need to get a form of transfer
called legislative land withdrawal that
we need to go to Congress
or Congress hasn't provided that yet and
we'll have to work with them as well
what happens if if New Mexico joins this
are a regional revolt are they going to
demand more safety standards than then
they might have given all the publicity
mr. well we need we need to have that
stored safely and there's must be a
solution if we don't have a solution for
storage new touring nuclear waste we've
got to stop producing them that's all
well I've been led to believe by top
security briefings by the Department of
Energy with other governors that this is
an essential part of the secure position
of our national defense some of the
low-level nuclear waste that is
generated in manufacturing triggers for
nuclear weapons needs to be deposited
somewhere the United States Department
of Energy believes it does have a
solution for unwieldly nuclear wastes
piling up a DOA facility in the south
eastern plains of New Mexico whip or the
Waste Isolation Pilot project nears
completion after 10 years construction
millions of years ago the ocean left
vast salt deposits here 100 acres of
connected caves have been carved into
these ancient salt beds one half mile
underground here a military nuclear
waste is destined to be sealed away for
a minimum of 10,000 years since the
Trinity test in 1945 do-e has designed
developed tested and produced nuclear
weapons a major byproduct of our defense
industry is transuranic waste paper
cloth metals and other products
contaminated with radiation the
radionuclides such as plutonium or
heavier than uranium thus transuranic
nuclear waste will be traveling through
28 States perhaps through your
neighborhood on its way to whip in
communities along the nuclear quarter
concern is growing
in the studio's krx radio studios we've
got with us this morning
Joni Aaron's and Carmen grease from
concerned citizens for nuclear safety
we're going to talk about the concerns
of concerned citizens for nuclear safety
and also about whip The Waste Isolation
Pilot project and the proposed
transportation of the nuclear waste
through the state of New Mexico to the
website in Carlsbad what is the
information that you have in reference
to the total nuclear waste that will be
transported through the state of New
Mexico the Department of Energy predicts
that there'll be fourteen hundred and
fifty shipments a year through New
Mexico i-25 will receive a thousand
shipments a year which will be about
three shipments a day past Las Vegas
other waste will be coming from South
Carolina and from Tennessee Ohio and
Illinois on i-40 but my major concerns
is that there'll be an accident it comes
right down Main Street it'll come all
the way down Main Street break off on
South East Main and in the process of
its route it goes within a block and a
half of three elementary schools the
city of Roswell has passed an ordinance
saying that the trucks will not be able
to come through
Roswell except between midnight and 6:00
a.m. do e is already challenging that
ordinance saying that that ordinance
won't be enforced these particular
routes that were talking about are
actually funded by the state and the
federal government they're considered
state roads and federal highways and so
the city has some interest obviously but
I don't think the city has 100% say as
to what we can do with in those areas
what if one of those trucks come by and
makes a you know hits the bridge and and
one of those containers go into the
river it's not going to affect me it's
going to affect hundreds and thousands
of millions of people down there down
river because it's going to contaminate
the water it won't be usable anymore to
fish it won't be edible anymore with no
evacuation plans no insurance policy
is available essentially and that's what
got me activated I got so angry that I
decided to take an ad out in the
newspaper a full-page ad trying to
educate people that whip was not down
there Witt was here first coming right
through town I'm more concerned about
these war as butane trucks that come
through our city
the gasoline trucks the sulfur trains
you know if you want to worry those
things are more important than worry
about then some gloves and some boots
and contaminated waste in a drum that's
going to be in another container that's
going to be sealed it I think they talk
hacks and gloves to keep the project
low-keyed to keep people uninvolved keep
people unaware of what's going on I
think the scope of it's a lot larger I
don't think that they're informing them
about the effects of plutonium I came in
very as a very active Oh conservative I
mean I have a military background I have
a weapons background they've worked in
the weapons industry I think they always
wanted us to think way being the
government that we have north no voice
no control nothing we can do trust us
we're your federal government believe in
us that's what they told the people in
Hanford that's what they told the people
in Savannah River Bernal
they're telling us that New Mexico not
acceptable again not acceptable my
problem with the DEA has always been
their attitude from the beginning which
was there are certain things that are
too sophisticated too complicated for
the public to understand and I felt that
there was no way that they could expect
people to make reasonable decisions
without knowing all the facts and that
if explained properly anybody not just
state government officials but anybody
could understand these issues the
problem I'm having is as a city official
I'm just interested what happens in her
I'm supposed to be knowledgeable and
trying to make the best decisions for
our people how can I do that when I
can't get two people to come up with the
same answer how can I do that when the
information changes how can it be all
the sudden that now we have something
which is not transgenic something which
is more hostile something which is more
lethal when we were told it was going to
be trans you're in what are we going to
have a transionic or is it not wastes
that are going to be shipped to with our
radioactive mixed waste now radioactive
mixed wastes are defined as as
radioactive waste which through the
process of their generation are also
contaminated with hazardous wastes as
defined by EPA under resource
conservation and Recovery Act and I
think this issue of what's in the waste
is a classic example I don't understand
how it could happen that we could have
gone through hundreds of pages of
environmental documentation and all
these years since 1980 when the final
environmental impact statement came out
which never said a word about mixed
hazardous waste how can it be that now
for the first time we hear about the
existence of that of the hazardous waste
mixed in with this transionic waste and
and the whole application of another
federal statute which was never
mentioned there's no excuse for that
happening now on the eve of when they
want to start with operations so my
feeling is that this whole attitude that
they started off with which is if you
knew what we knew but we can tell you if
that attitude is carried forward to
today and I think jeopardizes the
ability of the state and the federal
government just to do its job and a
whole democratic process that's that
lies behind that if there was an
accident with one of these vehicles
that's transporting some of this nuclear
waste what type of material is being
transported and could it be an
insignificant accident or could it be a
serious accident the trucks are going to
be carrying plutonium contaminated
materials in 55-gallon drums plutonium
is the most
toxic substance known to man if one
pound of plutonium was distributed
across the world every man woman and
child could die as a result of it this
plutonium atom has a terrific amount of
energy that releases although it has
very little penetrating ability once it
gets against the membrane of the small
passages and along it could a great
likelihood to cause cancer lung once in
the lung the plutonium lodges in the
tissues these yellow rays show tracks
made by alpha rays emitted from a single
particle of plutonium 239 this particle
can penetrate more than ten thousand
cells within its range
Tony MIT self actually causes most of
its damage through inhalation
but it can also cause damage by being
ingested especially if it's ingested
with chlorinated water now they find
that it does make its way through the
lining of the bowel and then it does
settle in bone causing bone cancer and
leukemia or it can settle in gonads and
in the germ plasm and affect the sperm
all over and cause genetic effects
transionic waste or any radioactive
waste or for any ways for that matter if
handled properly and handled with the
respect that they require are not
something to fear the problem with these
radionuclides is that they are dangerous
for very long periods of time plutonium
239 for example has a half-life of
24,000 years that means it takes about
240,000 years before it decays to a
level that would be considered not very
dangerous well it's true that that
radioactive materials last a long time
but they're also very easy to detect and
so if there would be an accident you
would merely scoop up the dirt around
the site and package it away much of the
waste is in solid form such as clothing
dirt or metal which could be picked up
and contained
the maximum accident in the case of
these nuclear leaks is very small
there's no potential for explosives for
explosion and there's a very little
likelihood that the material would move
very far from the accident scene so it
could be cleaned up we now know that 40%
of the hazardous waste is combustible
thus posing a more serious and immediate
threat 3% of and so on
I think the combustible waste is perhaps
the most significant because even a
layman can understand that when
combustible waste is exposed to high
levels of heat there may be some effect
inside the true pack and not just from
the exposure to the heat on the outside
wind is a critical factor which must be
considered the worst case scenario would
be if a fire occurs within a breach of a
container the wind could then carry
plutonium particles through the
atmosphere traveling considerable
distances as we learn more acceptable
doses of radiation becomes smaller
currently 5 rims is allowed for workers
in nuclear plants equivalent to 1000
x-rays on bone marrow I think you can
say that most scientists feel very
strongly that there is no safe threshold
for radiation there you go by what is
called a linear no-threshold theory that
doses doses accumulate the more those
you get the more the more health effects
the d.o.a claims people will not be
exposed to harmful levels of radiation
the waste will be transported in
specialty design true pack containers we
factor surrounded by three mini vaults
if you want three walls that are
stainless steel which includes a 10-inch
polyurethane hard core foam that acts as
a heat retardant and energy absorber
case of impact and this outer layer
basically protects that foam the foam
protects the inner layers of site so you
basically have min
faults within this troupe backflow this
is a formation it does have the
container looks impressive but it still
needs to pass Nuclear Regulatory
Commission testing in one test the
container was dropped 30 feet onto a
concrete slab in this test the outer
shell sustained a puncture the DOA
claims such punctures will not endanger
the contents in the second test the
container sustained a further break some
citizens feel that these tests are not
difficult enough and do not reflect real
life scenarios my concern about the true
PAC testing that I've read about is that
in the troop acts as I understand that
has been some kind of powdered cement
yet in the latest DL we document we find
out there's going to be about 85% of the
act of the transionic race is going to
be hazardous waste were mixed with
hazardous waste including combustible
materials and various other materials
that are listed as hazardous materials
under federal law therefore when they're
exposing the truth pack to fire intense
levels of heat to puncture tests it
would seem to me reasonable to at least
simulate the kinds of waste that will be
in there so that they have some validity
to their test what are the possibilities
of an accident occurring it woke a well
there's been 173 radioactive accidents
across the country 34 of those have
happened in New Mexico we do have some
rationale because we've been shipping
this waste from Rocky Flats and Colorado
after Idaho for you know a very long
period of time 25 years or more
and we have had accidents but there has
never been a release and there has never
been a release of radiation from a type
b container nairobi that with all the
transportation of all these high-level
wastes and transgenic ways we may be
ending up with Chernobyl's are along the
nuclear highways and because if there's
any ever any spill of plutonium of a
significant degree it will be so
devastating that it'll render large
parts of this country uninhabitable if
it trucks by going for it even if
something happens for neck well you
volunteer fire department or your fire
department would respond the State
Police are the ones that would take over
the situation when they responded one of
my services would be first responder to
a scene of an accident in in in this at
least in the city limits is to determine
the whether or not there is any
contamination as a result and and to
attempt to form some initial opinion as
to the degree of that contamination
Carlsbad had recently upgraded their
equipment with a hazmat truck however
Tully said first responders would not
necessarily have Geiger counters or even
protective clothing and the second
concern was that they were telling or at
least saying they're going to train the
emergency preparedness people in the
various communities along the lip loud
as to how to respond to an accident and
I didn't understand how they could even
begin to train these people if they
weren't able to tell these people what
kind of materials they were dealing with
we placed it into the responsibility of
our fire department and they are now
preparing the plan for what we shouldn't
can do in the event that a spill might
occur so to say that today we're ready
it would be not an accurate statement I
don't think we already since this
interview the Santa Fe Fire Department
received two official
a first responder kits containing one
plastic sheet two paper suits rubber
gloves one half face respirator and a
roll of duct tape I know we are not
equipped we have no equipment whatsoever
to handle any accident that might occur
but I'm sure that if there is any any
funds available for any special kind of
equipment then I'm sure that we will be
asking for for assistance in funding
this the whip trail is routed through
major populated areas across the nation
in Congress monies were promised for New
Mexico by passes and road improvements
no funds have yet been appropriate one
citizen has taken his concerns to one of
the busiest intersections in New Mexico
I was overwhelmed with the support that
I felt from passing drivers in the form
of them honking their horns in the in
the form of them shouting out the window
thank you for doing what you're doing
and I realized that in some way we as a
community at that moment had been
bottled up and we hadn't been we hadn't
had the opportunity for a long time to
express our feelings about about the
people's input about with Joni Aaron's
took her concern door-to-door along the
WIPP route what you say dropped it off
oh yeah what I would like to do is take
the signs and go along the routes and
educate the people along the routes and
let them know that the trucks are coming
by and what hazards are potentially
there all of these issues that get
raised when the government wants to
bring Tony incant Amma native waste on
the roads it's all going to convert here
in New Mexico in Santa Fe concerned
citizens for nuclear safety or see CNS
as grown into a powerful political law
credible is not precedent for this kind
of grassroots activism going against
somebody as powerful as the do-e and the
nuclear weapons industry in the defense
contractors we put 200 billion dollars
on defense contracts on hole and whip
didn't open so now we have people all I
think the most amazing thing about the
organization and about the whip is here
is what it's done to the community it's
brought us together we're learning how
government works they know how to write
testimony for Congress we know how to
lobby our legislators we know how to
activate phone trades we know how to
raise money we have to be very cautious
to at this point not to pat ourselves on
the back because we have a long road
ahead of us Sasha Pyle took her concerns
all the way Washington DC where she
testified to two House subcommittees
well we know now that more calls and
letters have been generated by the whip
issue than in any other issue in New
Mexico history and the calls and letters
have gone to the people here and to the
people in Washington and they do make a
big difference after our first meeting
we didn't even know if we were going to
have a second meeting and then some
other people joined and then some other
people called and today we were
literally in the thousands in the
biggest protest scene in Santa Fe s
history citizens from the northern part
of the state expressed concerns about
safety and future generation
to every woman and man who's worried for
your children welcome welcome to the
bigger family and to every New Mexico
person who's worried about the
contamination of this land welcome
you're not struggling alone anymore
we have sadness we have anger we have a
sense of frustration these feelings are
totally appropriate they're healthy
feelings and in fact they're in central
because we can't have a political
movement without our passion we need our
passion it cannot be demonstrated that
it's safe it has to be shut down yes in
that level where I stopped with Europe
but only if it can be proven that does
not say it there is little protest about
whip in the southern part of the state
where in the past people have had to
depend economically on failing
agriculture potash mining oil and gas
industries the whip has done some good
economically for us I don't think that
the federal government or any agency
would bring anything that would be
unsafe for us so we don't feel that this
is that unsafe then the best salesmen we
have is the guy that's working out there
making thirty five forty thousand
dollars it's got a job for the next
twenty five years with some security
that have to worry about the party's
prices he doesn't have to worry about
oil and gas he doesn't have to worry
about a layoff something like that and
now they're talking you know there's
enough waste out there for 75 years so
once we get this thing open I think
you're going to see this thing just just
really do be a great tremendous impact
to the state of New Mexico into Eddy
County and the city of Carlsbad I don't
think it's healthy employment situation
in this town we went through two or
three years of crisis time around here
when whip was at its peak and a lot of
people that did
welcome whip did so with the thought
that it would healthy economy New Mexico
gets much more money back from
Washington than its ends
to Washington in the form of taxes so
that says in itself that government is
big business in New Mexico early we have
those people standing in opposition to a
number of people from the Carlsbad area
who are saying my job is dependent on
well you know are the people in the
grants area he said my job used to
depend on uranium mining and milling and
I'd like for that industry to come back
okay so we have these this tug and pull
back and forth between people at
different ends of the spectrum in terms
of radioactive materials what I don't
hear a tremendous amount of from is the
citizens who have lived here from
multiple generations that's where I'm
not getting a great deal of input when
they work for a federal government it's
hard for them to speak against this
probe they could guess what the federal
government is doing on Indian land for
what it's doing to the people as a whole
they're afraid to lose their jobs they
depend on their jobs so therefore you
don't find too too many Native Americans
going out and attacking the federal
government they are afraid my feeling on
at least the Hispanic people is I've
always seen the Hispanic people as a
people of complacency I don't know they
they don't object to very much of
anything as far as their life is
concerned they're basically just living
surviving from day to day
fight the wit was picked just because of
the kind of people that lived here just
the fact that we are people that will
not protest much and that we take things
as they come
we are economically not too well
well-off most of us and so it was picked
just because of they weren't going to
get that much luck I've seen the that
most recently my activities has been a
minority twice as a woman and a Hispanic
has brought out a lot of the elderly
women in the Hispanic it's it's strange
but I think maybe it's that thing about
women being more active than men and
they've see the Hispanic tie and they're
coming out and asking little things like
what's going on and maybe if there's
anything I can do so I have hope for the
people who easily lay low I think
they'll come around it's just as the
radioactive waste disposal issue reaches
national proportions small communities
along the WIPP highways need to be
informed and involved our land is our
heritage the impending transportation of
radioactive materials by our homes
raises questions about our future
what exactly is in the barrels what is
the potential for accident
well the troop at containers safely
contain the waste
are we prepared to respond to an
emergency is there sufficient and
accurate public information is there
independent scientific oversight what
effect does whip have in our economy
what is the relationship between city
state and federal government does the
state have rights consider 'sons be more
involved
do we really have any decision-making
power to affect our nuclear military
industry
and the nation has three different
tracks for solving the radioactive waste
problem high-level the transionic rates
going to whip in a low level program all
of those are controlled by the
Department of Energy with is the first
one worthless at the model in the pace
in the entire routine by which the
nation deals with its radioactive waste
problems I have personally been involved
in directing the geotechnical studies in
the research program which evaluates the
grip region the website itself for its
ability to safely isolate radioactive
wastes I've been involved for these 13
years and I've become convinced that the
website is indeed a very safe and
satisfactory location that salt itself
is a very desirable medium for this
Waste Isolation well it's beneficial in
particular because it gives us a
laboratory on the deposition of nuclear
waste it provides jobs in the southern
part of the state strengthens that
economy and it completes the cycle of
the nuclear energy business that we've
had in New Mexico starting with the
science at Los Alamos through uranium
mining and refining on into the use of
those energy fuels and now back into
waste deposition so it just completes a
cycle that New Mexico is famous for we
know a lot about it and as a consequence
we should be involved in can't solve the
nation's radioactive waste problem for
the next 200,000 years with a political
solution in whip was not determined to
be the nation's radioactive waste dump
because it was geologically the best
site it was determined because
politically the leaders down there
invited the federal government to come
down to help them create some jobs and
then they had to create a framework
around that to prove that whip was in
fact the best place to put it and they
haven't proved it yet because it's not
geologically the best place in 1956 the
National Academy of Sciences recommended
disposal of radioactive waste and deep
geologic salt pits the Academy stated
that salt is plastic and that it creeps
to fill in cracks so many man-made
openings or any natural fractures that
might tend to occur
and other rocks will be healed well if
you go back and look at that earlier
report 1956 you see that the
recommendation was based on a belief
that salt was dry and that it would
remain dry these attributes of salt that
it is dry that salt creeps and heals
possible breaches that is inexpensive
and easy to mine that it transmits heat
well all add up to make salt appear in
1956 to be a solution to our radioactive
waste problems in the early 1980s
however conflicting scientific findings
came to light we now know today that a
number of those positive attributes of
salt are either not positive at all or
this particular site doesn't have the
positive characteristics for example the
web site is now clearly not dry while
there hasn't been enough water yet to
dissolve the salt there is water in the
salt creating corrosive brine which
therefore would very quickly destroy any
kind of metal containers that there
waste was in which means the waste would
be in the salt very quickly but two
visitors at WIPP the site appears dry
it's nothing like I had pictured it you
can just barely see the build-up and
it's dry and I'm going to tell you it's
very dry down there I would the way I
pictured it was that there was water
running all over well this isn't true
and people all the time visit WIPP and
they want to see all this brine we can't
show them any because it's coming in in
such tiny quantities it can't even be
observed without doing extremely careful
and detailed testing well we say there's
a lot of reasons why it's dry and that
is they're using fans right now to
evaporate the water that is essentially
seeping from the lives of the WIPP
project Roger Anderson has done some
calculations and Sandia laboratories has
done some calculations on the amount of
brine accumulation from the salt after
the WIPP project is closed there's a
range of numbers if you take the lower
range then the problem doesn't look too
bad
Sandia has chosen that lower range of
values if you take the mid to higher
level then we have a site that is
busting with
in 50 years to a hundred years I
realized that we're dealing with a
hazardous product and I found other
geologists that have been employed at
the site that find this site to be
absolutely a no-go situation because
they claim it's going to leak at some
point if at least it will get into my
environment and into my water supply and
I find that to be something I don't
think the Department of Energy is
honestly looking at EEG stands for the
environmental evaluation group and our
sole purpose is to evaluate the WIPP
project some of the major
accomplishments to date include the
relocation of the repository a mile and
a quarter to the south after the
interception of a 17 million barrel
Brian reservoir a mile from the center
of the WIPP site a mile north of where
the main shaft is at the WIPP site there
was a bore hole drilled in November of
1981 the department of energy at the
time felt there wasn't any brine there
independent scientists felt that there
was Brian there and the purpose of
drilling the hole was to see whether it
was or not so they drilled they hit the
brine
it's literally spurted to the surface
and over a million gallons flowed out at
the surface creating a mini lake new
findings reveal a highly pressurized
Brian reservoir beneath the WIPP site
the Environmental Protection Agency
realizes that people in the future
unaware of what is underground might
drill through such a slurry into the
brine reservoir this drill hole would
flush radioactive materials to the
aquifer above the site or carry
radioactivity directly to the surface to
what is known as the accessible
environment you address the aquifers
first we're very fortunate in that those
so-called aquifers carry very little
fluid they flow very slowly and our
studies to date show us that if such a
thing were to happen significant
radioactivity would not reach the
boundaries of the WIPP site within the
10,000 year regulatory period but
independent scientists think the danger
is much more imminent it's also possible
for the
and to come up and get into the aquifer
and move through that move fairly
rapidly the travel time now is is now
known to be rapid in a matter of months
or years and then it would emerge in the
Pecos River and get out into the
biosphere The Wrestler aquifer flows
into the Pecos River from the website
and the Pecos River downstream of
Carlsbad at that point so there it's not
used for drinking water for Carlsbad but
it does flow into Texas and it issues
both for drinking and irrigation and
livestock watering downstream we think
that this new discovery or they
awareness now that there is a brine
reservoir underneath the site is
probably enough so that the website
won't make the EPA standards we feel I
think as a consensus that what should
proceed that there is nothing in these
issues that should cause it to be
terminated or even slowed rip is
presently exempt from meeting EPA
standards because WIPP is designed as a
facility for research and development
with is exempt from NRC licensing WIPP
is also exempt from the hazardous waste
act and unless this act as amended which
shipments would be going to an
unlicensed facility and lastly the state
has no veto power one of the things that
that I think it's important to
understand is how this whole process got
started when I first 1981 went into the
negotiating room with the deal.we their
lawyers were there and I pointed out to
their lawyers and I said well there are
problems with this consultation and
cooperation agreement from the state's
point of view this needs to be modified
this needs to be modified and I told him
the ways in which the state needed to
have its rights protected at that point
the lawyer at the time for the deal we
leaned over the table to me and said you
don't understand we don't have any
obligation to do these things for you
you either accept the agreement that
we're offering you now or we'll just go
ahead and proceed period with it in
other words they were basically saying
to me we'll do this out of the goodness
of our heart and I didn't believe that
at the time I still didn't believe that
this consultation and cooperation
agreement is the only leverage the state
of New Mexico has at present New Mexico
representative Richardson sponsor to
in Congress which requires that whip
meet EPA standards before the land is
withdrawn from the Bureau of Land
Management and given over to do E's
exclusive control this is what the bill
that I have done it says that no waste
can come in whatsoever unless all EPA
standards are met all and they can't
have experiments the Senate version of
the land withdrawal bill does allow for
experiments these experiments are
controversial because they permit a
percentage of ways to be placed at WIPP
without meeting EPA standards the kind
of information that we need has to do
with how much gas will be generated from
the waste itself as the organic
materials in there the coveralls and the
booties and the rubber and the kimwipes
as this all disintegrates it forms gas
and we need to know the rate at which a
gas is produced and the kinds of gas
unfortunately we're not satisfied with
the experimental plan that delia's
provided to date in fact they the plan
really only provides for one experiment
to measure different types of gas being
generated from the different waste forms
and in an actual mining environment
there are some shortcomings in that they
don't fully portray the actual waste
that will be in place namely to be
pressurized at backfill and a number of
other characteristics think that the
whole idea of the 3% in the experiment
is a ruse to get the waste into the
website without having to demonstrate
compliance because quite frankly I think
that the Department of Energy is worried
that they might not be able to meet
those EPA standards and rather than have
to prove it in advance where we don't
have the waste here we have to start the
search for a new site they'd rather get
a certain amount of waste in there they
want 15% we fought it down to 3% we want
to see 0% if the bill does not passed by
the spring of 1989 the Department of
Energy may bypass Congress and take
control of the land administrative Lea
in the overall people
one whip to be proven safe and I really
firmly believe this this is not a PR
statement like way but if they have to
let us attempt to prove it's a sprint
it's is that we can't do that at the end
of that period then all this is new all
the demonstrations and babies are
concerned about if they'll back off and
let us get this thing open and give us
five years or testing like we want to do
and don't cut us back I think we can
prove it at work and if it doesn't take
it back and put it in in Rocky Flats or
Los Alamos or wherever it came from but
I think we're on the right track and
we've got a great program today the
Department of Energy is not published
any plans in the event that they have to
retrieve the ways would they return the
race to Idaho would they find another
facility in New Mexico would they put
the material in the first high-level
waste repository and if there are no
alternatives then perhaps each drum
should have stenciled on the side of it
to be returned to sender in five years
if WIPP proves unsuitable there are many
questions left unanswered citizens and
public officials are pressing for
accurate information the information has
been very hard to come by and the do-e
plays a particularly sophisticated shell
game with figures and you know how many
shipments a day for instance what's in
them the definition of radioactive waste
for low-level high-level transuranic
waste the concern that people have is
people being totally candid him and the
wasteful whimpers frequently
characterizing newspaper and elsewhere
as low-level nice well let's get snot
level that's a low level could be
disposed on the surface for about two
billion dollars less and we're going to
be spending on this
to credit 20 100 feet underground well I
don't think that the government presents
all the truth well it's the time we have
to dig and dig and dig and you know 50
20 years later 30 years later we find
out the truth the whole truth you know
Alberta's mother viola was a witness to
the first above-ground nuclear testing
and everybody thought it was a big
earthquake one got out the dish fell off
the cupboards and the house took off the
poor neighborhoods and smacked cracked
in half and it was hoped but we didn't
know it was an earthquake to us
lynchings in every all our crops we
tried our animals got sick sheep lost
the wool the cows lost her skin and I
keep thinking of all the things that had
happened in that round my god it was
that and we didn't know a thing about
nobody that land you a thing about they
still laugh they still don't know people
are still left there they still don't
mother and they're dying a cancer my
family's my sister better cancer my dad
Americans for my cousin two cousins that
a cancer the personal opinion that I
have at the Department of Energy is I
don't trust what they say they have when
they get scientific information that
shows there's a problem they suppress it
that they can't suppress it they
criticize and ostracize the scientists
that were better than off to challenge
them they make a lot of promises
verbally and in writing and don't keep
them whether they're legal agreements or
otherwise
they haven't run any of the facilities
that they're now operating across the
country in a way that's prevented this
massive contamination problem they find
themselves with now 200 billion dollars
worth of contamination problems turnips
have been identified to deep disposal
but the alternatives all have other
problems associated with them
ocean disposal would be a violation of
the London Convention seabed disposal
would cause problems if you wanted to
retrieve at some future point
transmutation although it can be done in
the laboratory is not a commercially
expedient alternative sending it in a
rocket to outer space would violate all
of the concepts of contaminating and
polluting space as well as raising the
specter of an accident on the launch pad
scientists have worked on waste disposal
for a shorter length of time than on the
overall nuclear industry waste disposal
wasn't emphasized as much in the early
days of the nuclear industry and I
believe now that the attention it's
getting will result in very workable
answers and we'll have to continue
seeking new answers and improved answers
there may never be an ultimate solution
but there is a good practical solution
at any point in time I don't think you
can get good solutions if your process
is bad and I don't think you can have a
good process if if the government isn't
very candid about all the aspects of the
project if you are candid and you have
an open mind and don't basically make
decisions and do studies that justify
decisions that were made years ago I
think you have a lot better chance in
coming to a successful conclusion or a
successful resolution to a problem
rip is really not the solution to the
waste problem it's a bad sight the
process has been bad the public has been
largely excluded the state doesn't have
veto rights there's no independent
technical oversight from NRC or other
bodies whether this is the best site in
the country
I've always refused to say we've got the
best site but certainly of the other
salt sites that were exam
both foregrip in the 1970s and for the
civilian radioactive program when they
were still interested in working at
Sault sites out of those potential sites
I think I can say we have the best night
in 1979 or whenever I submitted my
report I had concluded at that time that
it was not an ideal place the delaware
basin had some problems and one of these
was a dissolution of salt and the
occurrence of the brian reservoirs and
at that time we weren't aware of the
brine seepage problem but compared to
other geologic basins that contain salt
the delaware basin on my list anyway was
down near the bottom it is a mistake to
go forward with the project that is not
safe that is unsound that is leaking
that has water above and below it that
we know is not going to solve the
nation's permanent radioactive waste
problem it sets a bad precedent for the
nation and the nation can't say we have
solved the radioactive waste problem all
they can say it we've jammed it down the
throats of New Mexicans and we can say
we've solved the problem at they really
haven't Tama nation is happening now
it's not in the future and we need to
clean it up and more importantly we need
to call attention to how lethal the
byproducts of nuclear technology are and
the only way to start public awareness
towards shutting down that technology is
to make people realize there is no safe
way to dispose of it and it's killing us
now rip is designed to hold less than
1/10 of 1% of all the nation's nuclear
waste the six point three million cubic
feet that would go into WIPP is one
thousandth of the nation's way so that
even if they do create this problem with
web they're not creating a solution they
need 999 other websites so we still need
to look at alternatives and second of
all I really don't believe that geologic
repository is going to be the way I
think we need to have more respect for
our mother earth than to then to force
it to swallow this toxic excrement they
have been digging on Indian Reservation
in Laguna
for for uranium and now they want to
bring it back to stick it on earth
through this nuclear transportation
through this whip program they're taking
it out and bringing it back that can
never be
you cannot take take Mother Earth out
and make garbage out of it and stick it
back it doesn't work that way
it doesn't work that way every time you
produce problems you produce huge
amounts of radioactive materials as
wastes which is leaking out into the
hair into the soil and the water the
most precious thing we have is our water
supply if we contaminate our water
supply what is the what is the meaning
of national security
an overriding question remains for every
one of us what is our responsibility and
how far does it extend into the future
well I think when we're looking at the
possible destruction of the natural and
indigenous world within our own
lifetimes we have to realize that we
have a choice to make on a personal
level that's going to affect the future
the world for hundreds of thousands of
years we're dealing with a substance
plutonium that is lethal for 250,000
years as technology increases and as
knowledge increases we can't hold those
in the past responsible for what they
did not know and so maybe the future
won't hold us responsible for what we
did not know all we can do is the is the
best we can do nuclear waste is a crime
against humanity and those that are
infecting us should be prosecuted well
there's a regulatory piece of guidance
which addresses the question of how long
into the future should we assume
responsibility the people who struggled
with this question when developing the
EPA standard said that perhaps 10,000
years is a reasonable period of time I'm
very far because I got 30 grandkids and
four break grandkids and more coming
every day so you can imagine I feel
awful
I feel awful I feel real responsible
I think that's why I say something you
know I've got kids here and I've got
grandchildren here I thought that
project out there would endanger their
health and their welfare in the future
I'd be the first one to stop it but I
think that this town has a great future
I think the state of New Mexico has all
the generations which will ever live on
earth out here right now
so whether whatever we do to the genes
whatever we do to the to the sperm and
over of people will have its effect on
future generations from now to forever
more so that I'd like to leave the
planet in the same shape it was when we
found it when it was able to sustain
life in a healthy way
so that's forever if we misuse Mother
Earth and if we've misused the Sun and
if we misuse anything else then it's
going to it's going to come back on us
and and what we look at in Indian belief
and in traditional way of doing this is
that not to misuse anything but only to
ask for the goodness of whatever is
there if there will always be birth
and I hope when that birth comes that
they'll always they'll also see the
light the Sun will always be here and
that the tree will always be here and
the waters of the earth will be here
where they can take them by the hand and
drink this beautiful water like it was
before so they can see their reflection
of love and this water I hope for this
for the future generation of the peoples
here on earth